hey everyone welcome to your daily
equation and today I'm going to focus on
an equation that as you will see is
mathematically quite simple involves
nothing more than algebra and yet it
helps us gain insight into the answer to
a question that I'm frequently asked
maybe it's a question that has occurred
to you as well which is people said to
me hey when are you finally going to
test string theory and the answer I have
to give us look in principle string
theory makes predictions in principle
any theory that puts gravity and quantum
mechanics together that's worth its salt
makes predictions the problem the
challenge is that the predictions
require us to access realms of reality
that are quite extreme very very tiny
length scales very very large math
skills large energies and we just don't
have the technology to access those
extreme realms and if the person is
particularly inquisitive they'll go
further and say like how small length
scales how big are the mascots and I'll
tell them look you know on the order of
10 to the minus 33 centimeters really
tiny lengths or on the order of 10 to
the 19 times the mass of the proton
which on particle physics scales is is
enormous and if the person is not
particularly inquisitive they'll nod the
head and say okay I get it but if they
run a push drugs will say tell me where
you get 10 to the minus 33 Sandra it's
like where does that number come from
where does 10 to the 19 times the mass
of the proton come from or an analogous
question is how far can we turn back the
cosmic film of the Big Bang to get a
glimpse mathematically of the very
beginning of the Big Bang the answer
there is you can turn the film back to
about in principle by 10 to minus 40 3
10 to the minus 44 seconds the Planck
time again a very tiny tiny timescale
where do these numbers come from and
these numbers are known as the Planck
length the Planck mass the Planck time
so that's our subject for today I want
to derive for you bring this up on the
screen I want to derive for
you the so-called Planck length as well
as I'll quickly do Planck mass and the
Planck time and again as you'll see
nothing more than algebra is required
for this but you know I love it when
something mathematically simple gives
deep insight into the nature of the
world and the nature of the exploration
that we theoretical physicists are
engaged with okay not to get there to
orient our thinking you know I think
it's kind of nice to think about reality
and the fundamental theories that we
develop as giving us insight along three
particular qualities of the world three
particular
axes that I could say take to be the
speed axis and the mass axis and say the
size axis and associated with each of
these three qualities is a fundamental
theory of the world right we talk about
very very high speeds extremes of speed
if you really want to have a full
understanding of that you have to bring
in the special theory of relativity if
you want to know about how mass affects
the world you need to know how gravity
affects the world and our deepest
understanding of the force of gravity as
we'll discuss in some future episodes
comes from the general theory of
relativity and four extremes of size if
you want to understand the full quality
of the world that emerges when you
examine it under extreme microscopes say
and look at it on very small size scales
you need
quantum mechanics and associated with
each of these three fundamental theories
is a fundamental constant of nature that
gives us insight into the kinds of
speeds or masses or sizes that really
allow these theories to fully flowers to
show how they differ
from say a Newtonian description of the
world so we know that for speed and the
special theory of relativity the
fundamental number that comes in is the
speed of light which in everyday units
is 3 times 10 to the 8th meters per
second when you're talking about say the
axis of mass and say the general theory
of relativity the fundamental number
it's called Newton's constant I guess
you could call it Einstein's constant -
it plays a central role not just in
Newton's theory of gravity but nine
science general theory of relativity and
in you know the everyday units that we
typically use so this is about six times
six point six seven times ten to the
minus eleven meters cube kilograms
seconds squared and then finally if we
go to the size and the quantum mechanics
axis then those of you who have looked
at some of the previous episodes you
know that a number that comes into that
story Planck's constant off we look at
Planck's constant divided by two pi
which we call h-bar little cross in the
top and this is a fundamental number
that governs the quantum mechanical
effects the sizes of the quantum
mechanical effects relative to their
Newtonian counterparts and that in these
units is about well if I put in the in
the 2 pi then I got a divide through by
a factor of about 6 and that gives us
about 1.0 5 times 10 to the minus 34
kilogram meter squared per second okay
so you have these three fundamental
numbers that come from these three
fundamental theories that give us
insight along these three fundamental
axes and the thing that I want to stress
is that that of course the numerical
values of these constants depends upon
the units that you choose so where do
those units come from well historically
the unit's come from things in the real
world right the second where does it
come from we all know comes from the
rotation of the earth if you call that
24
hours to go around once if you divide
that day into these 24 units called
hours and then divide this unit called
the hour into 60 other units called the
minute and if you died each minute into
60 other units called the second you
have a definition of the second based
upon an actual physical process physical
object in the world and historically
that's where the second came from now as
we understand the world better we do
more sophisticated things like so where
does the second come from now so the
second comes from actually looking at a
cesium atom cesium 133 atom and when you
excite it what happens is the atom emits
some radiation as it falls back to a
less excited state and a particular
transition that people focus upon has
radiation that oscillates at a
particular frequency which is
9,192,631,770 cycles per second and
indeed you can use this to define the
second what's the modern-day definition
of the second
it's the duration of time that it takes
this radiation emitted in this
particular transition of the cesium 133
atom to undergo 9,192,631,770 cycles
that's the definition of the second a
more precise definition it still makes
use of a thing an object a process in
this case cesium oscillating instead of
the earth rotating but it's one that we
have greater control over similarly what
about like the meter old days the meter
was a fraction of the distance along a
great circle from the equator to the
North Pole
I think they chose a great circle that
passed through Paris of all places and
you take a particular fraction of that
length and you define that to be the
meter modern date we can do better than
that we can actually use the speed of
light right I mean so if the speed of
light is this number over here you can
be
precise about that not exactly 300
million meters per second but the point
is you measure the speed of light define
it to be that particular number and in
save yourself what will the meter be the
meter will now be defined to be the
distance that light travels in one over
that number one 300 million I can't even
pronounce that one 300 millionth of a
second that top one to say or whatever
the precise number there should be you
know two hundred ninety nine million
whatever the precise measurement that we
have of the speed of light turn that
around and use that to define the meter
so the point is when you have these
fundamental numbers about the world
their values depend upon the units and
in fact you can use these fundamental
numbers to define the units and that's
what I'm gonna do right now so I'm going
to introduce now this notion that we
physicists often call natural units and
I will express these natural units in
terms of the familiar everyday units so
that we have an understanding of how big
the natural length scale is or how
massive the fundamental mass scale is or
how short in duration the fundamental
time scale is but the unit's themselves
are going to come from the fundamental
constants themselves and the intuition
here is the fundamental constants are
are telling us about the basic structure
of space time and energy and therefore
somehow our our view to be not somehow
they're really are viewed to be as more
fundamental than some arbitrarily chosen
specific process in the world be it the
rotation of the earth or the vibration
of say a cesium atom the natural units
are something that are universal that we
could even converse with aliens about
our units and if we use the natural
units will easily be able to translate
through the natural units understand
what their particular historically
contingent units are relevant relative I
should say to our historically
contingent you know you know the
kilogram the meter and the second okay
how am I gonna do it's quite
straightforward so what we're going to
do is we're going to take our three
fundamental constants C H bar and G and
all we're going to do is multiply them
together with particular exponents alpha
beta and gamma and we're simply going to
choose the exponents in order that this
particular product has the units say of
a length or has the units of a mass or
has the units of a time and a particular
numerical values expressed in everyday
units of that Lane scale or that mass
kolja time scale that will give us the
notion of a natural unit and that's
where the notion of a Planck length or a
Planck mass or a plane time will come
from so let me just do if that sounds a
little complicated or confusing let me
just do one example you see how
straightforward this is so let's now
derive the Planck length Planck length
how do we do that okay we're simply
going to say to ourselves choose alpha
beta and gamma so that this particular
combination has the units of a length
how do we do that well we do dimensional
reasoning dimensional analysis
dimensional analysis is a very powerful
and potent way of gaining insight into
things where you don't have to do very
detailed calculations it just gives you
the order of magnitude understanding of
the kinds of effects that are happening
so I should probably do a whole episode
on dimensional analysis but here we're
going to use it for one specific purpose
and has it work so let's start with see
what are the units of C C is a speed so
in everyday units it has the units and
we often use a square bracket the units
here are a length scale which I'm going
to confusingly put in an M there for
meters that's not mass its meters for
mass I'll put kilogram so it has a
meters
say a second in everyday unis I'm gonna
work in everyday units but I'm going to
drive the Planck length in terms of
everyday units so it has meters and a
second so if I have a seat through the
Alpha what are the units of the seat to
the Alpha well clearly I'll have my lane
scale my meters to the Alpha and I'll
have my time scale which is downstairs
to the minus alpha good
okay what about Planck's constant H bar
well H bar what are its units it's got a
kilogram meter squared per second and if
you raise that to the beta what I'll
have
there is I'll have my lane scale meters
to the two beta because I've got a two
over here and I will have my seconds
downstairs so they'll be to the minus
beta and now I've got my kilograms my
mass and kilogram is to the first power
so if I do an H bar to the beta I will
have a kilogram to the beta good
all right in fact I'm gonna give myself
a little bit more room here and I'll
just use my capacity to just move that
over there good okay let me now finish
up by putting in my G to the gamma I
don't want to emphasize my G to the a
Mike G to the camera all right so G has
a length cubed upstairs and then you've
got your mass and your time squared
downstairs so if you raise that to the
gamma I will have my length to the three
gamma and then I'll have my time seconds
to the minus 2 gamma and I will have my
kilogram downstairs to the minus gamma
so that's just in terms of my units of
course again this guy here is my C my
units of C to the Alpha this here is my
units of H bar to the beta and this here
gives
my units of G to the gamma all right now
all I want to do is choose alpha beta
and gamma so that I will have said the
units of a length and that just gives me
three equations in three unknowns right
because if I now say rewrite this as my
length scale my meters I get an alpha
from my C I get a two beta from my H bar
to the beta and I got a three gamma from
my G to the gamma and if I now say put
in my seppings here I got a minus alpha
from the sea I got a minus beta from the
H bar and I get a minus 2 gamma from my
G and then finally if I put my kilograms
in here I get here a beta from the H and
I get a minus gamma from the G and all I
need to do now is write down my 3
equations so I'll do them in reverse
order
I want beta minus gamma to be equal to
zero
so I won't have any kilogram in the
particular combination that I'm looking
at and I want also my alpha minus beta
minus 2 gamma to sort of look like
Emma's sorry to be equal to zero so I
don't have any time any seconds in this
combination and I want my alpha plus 2
beta plus three gamma I want that to be
equal to one so that my units are length
to the first power so now I just have
three equations and three unknowns and
that's something that's quite
straightforward for me to solve so let's
just do that so we learned that beta
must equal gamma from the first equation
if I put that into the second equation
I'll have minus alpha minus gamma minus
2 gamma equal to zero namely minus alpha
minus 3 gamma that's an alpha equal to 0
or in other words I get alpha equal
minus 3 gamma from my second equation
and then finally I'll stick that all
into my third equation so I'll have 4
alpha put minus 3 gamma 4 plus 2 beta L
plus
I'll put plus 2 gamma and then plus 3
gamma is equal to 1 and then I get to
gamma equal to 1 and gamma equals 1/2 so
that's my gamma and given that I know
that beta equals gamma so beta equals
1/2 and then my alpha what does my alpha
equal to well alpha equals -3 Yama's
that's minus three-halves and there you
have it so I now have my alpha my beta
my gamma to ensure that I get a length
out of here so let's write down that
particular combination C to the Alpha H
bar to the beta G to the gamma and that
is my Planck length so let me put that
down as my finale here so my Planck
length equals okay so see the Alpha H
part of the beta G to the gamma that
means that I will have a square root so
I'll just do the the half part for all
of them
so the beta at the gamma give me the H
bar and G upstairs squared of H bar G
the Alpha which is associated with seats
minus three-halves which is a 3
downstairs and there it is there is the
formula for the Planck length and in
terms of everyday units you can now plug
in the values that we have over here for
the constants in everyday units so again
here they are and if you just plug them
into a calculator and work out you will
find that the numerical value of this is
equal to that that duh so it's about 10
to the minus 35 meters and if you put in
the numerical factor 1.6 times 10 to the
minus 35 meter and this is on the order
of also 10 to the minus 33 centimeters
which is the number that I typically
quote when I talk about this and that's
where this fundamental length comes from
10 to the minus 33 centimeters you can
play the same game for the Planck time
go through it because it's just the same
algebra but if you work it out using the
alpha beta gamma approach that we have
for this this would give us square root
of H bar G over C to the fifth and this
is about 10 to the minus 43 10 to the
minus 44 seconds and for the Planck mass
again just choose alpha beta and gamma
so that the units of the combinations C
to the a part of the beta G to the gamma
has the units of the mass and that one
gives you square root of H bar times C
over G to do that correctly for Planck
mass ya think that's right and that is
about 10 to the I should've written this
one down I think it's about two times
ten to the minus eight kilos which I do
know is about 10 to the 19 times the
mass of the proton and that's where that
particular number comes from so there
you have it Planck mass Planck time
Planck length now just to finish up well
it releases the significance of these
numbers and and here's how to think
about it when we have a given theory
right whatever string theory any theory
let's say that involves gravity quantum
mechanics special relativity general
relativity quantum mechanics these three
numbers CH bar and G are what allow us
to link our mathematical calculations to
in principle observe observable
qualities of the world how does that
work well we we set out without here we
do some calculation and the result of
our calculation let's say we're
calculating the length of something we
will undertake some mathematical
calculation that will give us an answer
of the form the mathematical calculation
times a unit of length of her calc
the length of something and the unit of
length that will emerge in our theory is
determined by the only numbers in the
theory that have dimensions which are C
H bar and G and therefore the unit of
length that will emerge in our
undertaking our theoretical undertaking
will be our mathematical calculation
times the Planck length and typically
not always but typically the result of
the calculation this part over here will
be a number that we like to think of as
basically on the order of one you know
might be sportive - it might be e might
be pi squared which is like you know 10
but it won't be typically a number that
is like 10 to the 30 or 10 to the 50
right so the typical length that will
emerge from the theory that involves
gravity quantum mechanics special
relativity general relativity quantum
mechanics will be on the order of the
Planck length and similarly for
calculating the mass or something the
energy of something it'll be the similar
kind of thing typically it'll be a
number of order one that emerges from a
detailed mathematical calculation within
the theory times the natural mass scale
in a theory that involves C G and H bar
C G and H bar define a natural Maskell
the Planck mass that we just calculated
and therefore the typical mass or energy
scales will be on the order of 10 to the
19 times the mass of a proton and that's
why we typically say to test string
theory we need an accelerator that can
probe those fantastically large energy
scales a Large Hadron Collider can probe
to about roughly 10 to the 4 times the
mass of a proton so 15 orders of
magnitude larger now look it's not
impossible just to finish this up that
if you're very clever that you can do
say some calculations say within
in theory that might yield a number in
this slot that isn't order one maybe you
can identify some quality of the theory
that when you calculate the energy or
mass scale at which it could be testable
probable maybe it will get a number like
10 to the minus 15 or 10 to the minus 16
out of this in which case the number
that would emerge would be something say
on the order of 10 to the 3 times the
mass of the proton which would be well
with M the ability of the Large Hadron
Collider to probe for instance we had
hoped that supersymmetric particles
these are particles that naturally
emerge in a theory that has a
supersymmetric quality super in
supersymmetry refers to that maybe I'll
do an episode on it but for now let me
just note that we had hoped that there
was a symmetry supersymmetry that would
ensure that the number that came in this
slot was very very close to zero zero is
a natural number that emerges when
there's a high degree of symmetry
there's no number that's more symmetric
than zero no matter what you multiply
zero byte stays zero like when you have
a symmetric snowflake no matter how you
turn it if it's the right angles it'll
look the same zero no matter what you do
in terms of say multiplication division
it will stay zero so it's a highly
symmetric number so the hope was that
the symmetry would not be completely
evidenced in nature might be slightly
so-called broken giving rise to not zero
but a small number that would take the
natural scale of quantum gravity string
theory and reduce it to a level that we
might be able to probe at the Large
Hadron Collider so the hope was that
these supersymmetric particles would be
that clever theoretical structure with
in string theory that might be
experimentally observable and so far
this has not happened we've probed this
mask and we haven't seen these
supersymmetric particles but it's just
to say that in principle there
can be special qualities of a theory
even whose mass scale is enormous that
might be subject to experimental
observation using today's equipment but
so far that theoretical hope has not
borne fruit
we've not been able to test these
theories as yet anyway I hope that gives
you a sense of where these fundamental
lengths masses and times emerge Planck
length Planck mass and Planck time comes
right out of the fundamental constants
of nature we've now seen the formula for
them and that those three I would say
our today's daily equations and we'll
carry on with these ideas in subsequent
episodes send in your questions until
next time this has been your daily
equation take care